منطاد في سماء ملبده بغيوم ازمه متراكمه
بين واشنطن وبيجين تحلقه في اجواء ولايه
مونتانا الامريكيه اضاف اضطرابا اخر الى
علاقات بلدين ليست في افضل ايامها توجد في
مونتانا قواعد جويه ومخازن وصواريخ
استراتيجيه قضيه منقاد التجسس دفعت وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
الى تاجيل زياره لبيج كانت مقرره الاثنين
المقبل علق مسؤول امريكي بالقول ان واشنطن
واثقه من استمرار الحوار مع بيجين رغم
ارجاء الزياره مضيفا ان تحديدا موعد جديد
لها سيكون بعد توفر الظروف الملائمه على
حد قوله كبار المسؤولين نصحوا الرئيس جو
بايدن باستبعاد خيار اسقاط المنطاد بسبب
مخاطر حطامه فحجمه يعادل 3 حافلات وفق بعض
التقديرات وقبل قرار عدم الاسقاط جاهزه
مقاتلات بعضها من طراز اف 22 في ولايه
مونتانا كان متحدث باسم البنتاجون اوضح ان
المنطاد لا يشكل تهديدا عسكريا او جسديا
لمن هم عدا الارض عن بعد عقد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويند اوستن اجتماعا مع كبار
المسؤولين في البانتاجون كان اوستن في
مانيلا التي بحث فيها مع المسؤولين
الفلبينيين تهديدات الصين في المنطقه
ونشاطاتها المثيره للجدل في بحر جنوب
الصين علقت بيجين على القضيه بعده تصريحات
تطورت صيغها مع تطور التداعيات اذ اعلنت
الحكومه الصينيه ان المنطاد مجرد اداه
مدنيه للبحث العلمي ودخوله المجال الجوي
للولايات المتحده تم عن غير قصد وبسبب قوه
قاهره وقبل ذلك نفات المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه ان تكون لبلادها نيه
لانتهاك اراضي اي دوله او الجوي دعيه
لجانبين الى العمل معا بهدوء وحذر بحذر
تراقب كندا ايضا تحركات من اخر في اجوائها
دون ذكر اسم الصين في اوج تحذيرات امريكيه
بان الصين هي اكبر تحدي امني تواجهه حاليا
يخفض علو من طرد فرص عدم تاجيج الوضع
المتاسم قائمه الخلافات الطويله ومتشعبه
منها تايوان وبحر جند بالصين وحلفوشي
غير المرغوب فيه ما يفرق بين وعشره وبيجين
هذه الايام كثيرا وعابر للقارات